[Música]
nos encontramos con el gobernador de la
provincia de savory allá alexander stubb
muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros y empiezo con la primera
pregunta cuál es la situación en esta
provincia al día de hoy
la situación es diferente creo que ensa
por ella en realidad no ves la guerra la
gente camina por la calle lo único que
me recuerda a la guerra son los puntos
de control y el hecho de que haya muchos
militares directamente la situación es
diferente en la región la región es muy
grande tiene 27 mil kilómetros cuadrados
es como un país europeo pequeño en
tamaño y nuestra situación es tal que
parte de la región está ocupada parte de
la región están luchando otra está bajo
el control de las autoridades la
situación es completamente diferente en
tres realidades ya que se lucha
directamente cada día hay gente en
peligro que sigue viviendo también hay
civiles muertos
en la primera realidad está la verdadera
guerra la que está en marcha con los
bombardeos y ataques de artillería
lamentablemente la mayoría de la gente
abandonó ese territorio no todos en la
segunda está el territorio ocupado que
ha estado bajo influencia durante dos
meses dos meses con una situación
completamente diferente
hay actos terroristas de la potencia
ocupante secuestros decenas de personas
han sido tomadas como rehenes las
personas son registradas presionadas
regularmente están dividiendo familias
obligándolas a huir la tercera situación
es el territorio controlado que trabaja
y lucha al mismo tiempo
en la medida que las tropas rusas se van
liberando de las batallas por ejemplo de
mariupol teme usted que tengan un avance
más hacia el norte de esta provincia y
cuál es su principal temor en seguridad
la principal línea de ataques de hoy se
dirige al cerco de operaciones de
fuerzas conjuntas y militares ubicados
en la región de donges y parte de este
golpe va a la región de zamorilla por
que bordeamos directamente con la región
de donges bueno está claro que mariupol
se llevó la peor parte la ciudad y la
gente de mariupol dieron una oportunidad
a todas las demás ciudades y a la vez
tiempo para fortalecerse hicimos todo
para evitar el avance hacia la ciudad
consideramos que es necesario detener al
enemigo en enfoques distantes que no
hubo oportunidad de disparar a la ciudad
con armas y tanques
parte de la provincia está en control de
las tropas rusas que sabe usted de lo
que está pasando allí cuál es su
información y cuál es la proporción de
su provincia en control de ellos
si
la mayor parte de la información suele
ser de estas ciudades estas comunidades
porque nos comunicamos constantemente
con los líderes de la comunidad algunos
de ellos viven esa polilla se mudaron a
sap orilla y administran sus comunidades
directamente desde esta ciudad parte
permaneció en su lugar periódicamente
hay comunicación aunque en algunas
comunidades ha sido nula por supuesto
todo ha sido por medios electrónicos
el covent nos enseñó no solo a trabajar
de forma remota sino también a
administrar entonces hay comunicaciones
en general pero entendemos que la gente
ahí también está bajo presión además la
información se recopila de otras fuentes
directamente los ciudadanos con sus
teléfonos redes sociales o mensajes
usted se ha referido a que ellos tienen
métodos terroristas que sabe usted qué
es lo que está pasando en esa zona
el ejército ruso tomar rehenes roba
propiedades arrasan con todo a su paso
van a los pueblos y lo resuelven a su
manera tomando todo lo que les gusta y
quienes se oponen pueden ser torturados
los disidentes políticos pueden ser
golpeados encerrados en sótanos o en la
cárcel esto sucede sistemáticamente
por el momento tenemos información de
que ciertas personas están secuestradas
hay menores siendo retenidos los
allanamientos se llevan a cabo
regularmente entran en la casa y dan
vuelta a todo hemos documentado una gran
cantidad de estos hechos depende del
territorio son como una horda cuando
entran a las poblaciones
también sabemos que hay diferentes
grupos técnicos
los buriatos generalmente hablan mal el
ruso tiene su propio patrón de
comportamiento de chechenos pero todo se
trata de dinero
hay diferentes patrones de
comportamiento para las situaciones casi
la misma nos preocupa principalmente
secuestro de personas en parte motivado
por causas políticas pero también por
motivaciones económicas hemos visto como
han secuestrado empresarios para pedir
rescate
la polilla recibe a miles de desplazados
en las últimas semanas y meses cuantos
desplazados hay actualmente en la ciudad
y cuál es el impacto económico y social
que tienen en sap orilla
tenemos registro de más de 50.000
personas desplazadas pero en total más
de 250.000 personas han hecho tránsito
por saborío por la región directamente y
cerca de 150.000 ucranianos que llegaron
aún permanecen en la ciudad o la región
nosotros tenemos programas estatales
gracias al apoyo que hemos recibido de
europa y otros países estamos muy
agradecidos con el apoyo económico
internacional porque muchas personas ya
no pueden asumir sus cargas laborales
hay familias divididas muchos de
nuestros hijos y parientes están en
polonia república checa países bajos
alemania y muchos otros países
hemos dado prioridad a los grupos
socialmente vulnerables para ayudarlos a
transitar hacia los países occidentales
son las regiones más occidentales del
país porque allí la situación es más
tranquila y podemos brindar apoyo con
nuestras instituciones sociales a pesar
de que hemos tenido cerradas las
escuelas
también cuando podamos reabrir el apoyo
social en nuestra región lo haremos
porque sabemos el grado de destrucción
que hay ya tenemos en marcha programas
de gobierno para dar reembolsos de los
costos que han tenido que asumir
nuestros residentes
esto ha sido gracias a las decenas de
fondos internacionales de la 1 y
bilaterales
la cruz roja también ha brindado
asistencia material
no ha sido un trabajo fácil de organizar
en medio de esta crisis pero hemos
brindado ayuda
qué sabe usted actualmente lo que está
sucediendo en estos últimos días de lo
poco que queda de batalla mariupol las
fuerzas que quedan adentro los civiles
cuál es la situación dentro de la ciudad
cuando me hacen esta pregunta a los
periodistas suelo responder que estoy en
sap orilla para saber lo que pasa ya
tienes que estar en mariupol o muy cerca
de mariupol muchos continúan su vida
intentan no ver el horror pero hay
muchas personas en los sótanos de as
hostal que siguen siendo bombardeados
las dimensiones de esta tragedia las
empezamos a vivir desde marzo cuando
vimos directamente el primer flujo de
personas entre 5000 y 7000 personas
salieron por día de mariupol porque como
hemos visto la ciudad fue demolida
tuvimos que entender que esta crisis
durará y va para largo nos hemos
encontrado con muchas historias
provenientes de esta ciudad y estamos
documentando esas historias
actualmente los combates tienen lugar en
la mayor parte de la ciudad sólo en
asobal en la parte principal de la
ciudad la lucha cesó en las últimas
horas
pero hay una situación social difícil
porque no hay gas no hay electricidad
es una catástrofe humanitaria y
seguramente se profundizará al no haber
agua ni electricidad durante mucho
tiempo la situación seguirá
deteriorándose
desconocemos si hay existencias de
alimentos
sabemos que ya no es posible ir a un
supermercado o incluso a abrir el
refrigerador
muchos almacenes ya no tienen alimentos
suficientes como terminará todo esto es
una situación bastante difícil
japón y ya acoge una de las plantas
nucleares más grandes de europa sino la
más grande que sabe usted de la
situación de esta planta nuclear está
segura y teme por la seguridad
sabemos que la planta de energía nuclear
está completamente bajo el control de la
empresa estatal ucraniana en el boato
nuestros ingenieros eléctricos
permanecieron allí a pesar de las
condiciones adversas
esta es una presión constante pero está
la necesidad de garantizar la seguridad
de esta instalación
desafortunadamente todas las reglas que
se aplican a tales situaciones no
funcionan
nos enfrentamos al hecho de que muchas
de las organizaciones internacionales no
pueden ir más allá de los discursos
sobre la energía nuclear
constantemente surgen dificultades es
necesario dotar a la estación de
componentes para reparaciones y
reactivos químicos para que funcione
llegar allí es un problema cada vez
mayor se ha utilizado una central
térmica para equilibrar la central
nuclear y debido a que los invasores
volaron la vía férrea no hay forma de
entregar para el funcionamiento de la
central térmica las personas de sus
familias viven bajo ocupación y los
hechos violentos no agregan confianza a
quienes están en las plantas nucleares
puede haber un error somos un país que
sobrevivió a chernóbil
y cree usted que hay una posibilidad de
que saab orilla termine en manos de las
fuerzas rusas
es posible o imposible bueno la invasión
ya está ahí y zamorilla ha estado
luchando durante dos meses bueno diré
que sí aquí tuvimos a los cosacos de sap
orilla no sé si es familiar este
acontecimiento histórico de ucrania pero
los cosacos nunca se arrodillaron ante
nadie solo ante dios
muchísimas gracias por estar con
france24 en español esta mañana
[Música]
bien